good morning good morning president
Levin Provost's olive a vice president
and secretary Lorimar chaplain Coogler
masters deans and honored guests and
welcome women and men of the class of
2015 welcome
welcome to Yale University and welcome
to Yale College I'm well we are so
excited to have you here we've been
thinking about you since april one when
dean Brens all of admissions told us
your names then we met some of you
during bulldog days we met a few more of
you this week in orientation programs
but at last 2015 you are here no
hurricane could stop you welcome inside
the walls the playing fields the
classroom Studios labs and most of all
into the residential colleges welcome to
the spaces and places you will soon call
home and welcome to all the families and
friends who brought you to this day
you've come from Ghana and new haven
from California in China from Berkeley
Bowling Green Brookline in Brooklyn
thanks for having helped 1352 of the
world's most interesting and smartest
young people find their way to today
we're going to have exceptional
encounters with them over the next few
years but 2015 my business is with you
lately it has seemed as though the world
as we know it is about to end will it be
the collapse of the global economy will
there be an outbreak of a previously
unknown disease or a well-intentioned
science project run amok as some of you
may have seen in a summer film film
starring Yale's own graduate student
James Franco for a while this summer one
could even wonder whether the days of a
hundred plus degrees would ever end and
then hearth Club earthquakes struck
unusual parts of the country Virginia
Colorado hurricanes these anxieties can
be hard to get a grip on but apocalyptic
dread runs deep some of us here today
remember the anxieties that seemed to
take concrete shape on the day john f
kennedy was shot most of you
recall some of the first thoughts that
flickered through your minds on 911 two
years ago on this occasion of the
freshman assembly I spoke to current
juniors about the Maya calendar and the
question of whether it would end and the
world with it in december 2012 which is
right around the corner now only to
assure them along with their parents and
guests as I now assure you that this end
date is in the Maya calendar pretty much
just a mechanical problem one in which a
large number like an odometer in an old
car turns 20 and starts anew and so it
will nevertheless the Maya calendar
notwithstanding and I should tell you
that I'm a specialist in the study of
the ancient new world the end of the
world was a common belief in most of the
religions of the ancient new world and
it is in most of the world's religions
the Aztecs believed that the world would
end in earthquakes when the fifth son
collapsed the earth convulsing as the
heavenly body fell on its surface humans
eliminated darkness ensuing but it
wasn't like that at all in 1519 when
their world did come to an end with the
invasion of the Spanish yet there's no
doubt about it that's what happened and
their world came to an end although not
with the swiftness of science fiction
over the course of the 16th century
probably about 90% ninety percent of
indigenous peoples would die in what
quickly became known as New Spain from
new diseases disturbed environment
disturbed lifeways in the sheer
oppression in retrospect we can see how
the Spanish found ways to tell their
version of the story starting first with
hernan cortes own heroic and nuanced
account of how he and his soldiers
overcame unbelievable odds within a few
years they're almost fantastical stories
of conquest
weren't likened to what was known about
Roman conquests triumphs that saw the
Spanish king also in that day holy roman
emperor in the role of the great Roman
Caesars in this the Spanish collapsed
their own present atop their own past
seeing the great potential for religious
conversion as akin to both reconquest
spain and the early days of Christianity
and an antidote to the rise of Martin
Luther's protestant apostates the
conquistadors experienced a sort of time
travel in which their discovery of a
world previously unknown to them a world
without knowledge of Christianity and in
which precious gold was abundant seemed
a kind of paradise but what were the
Aztecs themselves to make of this
religion in history about which they
previously knew nothing but which was
now ascribed to them were the Aztecs
living in someone else's past their
resistance in 1521 was fierce some 60
years later as part of a vast
encyclopedia that father saha goon
compiled the children or grandchildren
of Aztec Nobles now in that day
described by a new and collective term
Indian recalled what they had heard of
the story and they wrote it down that
the defeat had found and achieved such a
voice is in itself unusual take a look
at the picture in front of you you all
have one in and look at the text to the
right of it in anak motecuhzoma c'mon
Sam Okla TK manoj k keith lawal cocky
when market soma was made prisoner they
not only hid themselves and took refuge
they abandoned him and they Illustrated
what had happened often one image linked
to another like those of a pre
Hispanic book now if you received a
Christian religious education you may
think that you recognize the picture in
front of you as an image of Jesus but it
is instead the image of motorcade soma
seized by Spanish soldiers rendered as
if it were the moment of some 1,500
years earlier in that pivotal moment of
Christian history when Jesus of Nazareth
was taken by Roman soldiers as my
student Dianna megaloney now director of
the National Museum in Mexico City first
realized just a decade ago the visual
language of Jesus's death and Monica's
oma's death are conflated whose story is
this and the sentence I just read you
when I return to this page this summer I
recognized another echo of the Gospels
in the names of market soma supporters
listed here all abandoning him just as
he seized by soldiers like the apostles
who abandoned Jesus this book survived
only because of Franciscan missionary
took it to Italy probably against the
direct orders of the Spanish crown where
it was not to be rediscovered for 400
years it so easily could have been lost
all together steadily mind for its
content since the late 19th century the
volumes of this great book called many
stories not yet recognized without this
book a very different story of the new
world would be told a simplified picture
like the difference between a
two-dimensional representation and a
three-dimensional one between a map and
a painting as Yale historian John gatos
discussed some years ago in his
meditation on landscape in history once
a work like this is known to exist
becomes a fixed element of the landscape
a known mountain or heavenly body a
boulder to be reckoned with yet as fixed
as a work like this may seem to be in
the world it continues to change as new
eyes look at it and
new questions challenging that's been
true for me over so many years of study
of long known objects or newly
discovered ones old buildings old cities
and once things have changed they're
never the same again just like the
picture you have in front of you it
changes you when you see any fragment of
the world a new light pictures change
documents change landscape changes even
when they seem to stay the same received
experience and wisdom which all of you
have been building for about 18 years
now may suddenly insist upon being
reconsidered now that you're in college
things you studied may start changing as
the questions change and his new light
falls upon them for me that metaphor of
change is so personal I grew up on a
small working farm about 300 miles from
here every spring when my father began
his plowing he would find his days vexed
by rocks some of them boulders that had
been heaved up by the freezing and
thawing of the winter he carried a
six-foot crowbar on the back of the
tractor to pry loose those recalcitrant
rocks and moved them to the hedgerows
sometimes he'd turn up one that he
particularly admired a lot a lump of
limestone say studied with studded with
fossils that I later would learn predate
dinosaurs or a boulder of granite
embedded with quartz crystals slabs of
shale would flake like fine puff pastry
yielding trilobites what seemed to
outsiders to be the most stable part of
our universe the land itself was
constantly in motion our present turning
up new elements of the past we now ask
you to prepare for the future by
studying many things and many of them
new to you recent grads as well as grads
of years long past often tell me that a
course they took far outside their
comfort zone whether in photography or
Chinese poetry or a theology or stew
istics has helped them more in their
lives than they ever could have imagined
especially when they then see the world
differently it's as if they've picked up
a rock that's put itself in their way
changing their understanding of the
picture they've seen before and just for
a second when this happens to you you
stop letting the value and complexity of
that rock that impediment register many
of the positions that you will hold in
your careers 15 20 years from now don't
exist today so more than ever it would
be a mistake to prepare for the future
through too narrow or cautious an
approach to the studies that you're
about to commence given how much
fearlessness you will need and facing
the unknowns of your future and your
future careers don't be afraid to take a
class in geology or anthropology or my
own fields archaeology and art history
if there's a subject that interests you
this is the time I assure you there will
never be another one quite like this to
dip your toe into Hindi or the New York
Mambo you're in this Yale College moment
now you're prepped for the days ahead
but you're also just here and that's an
increasingly challenging place to be
after all you are all multitaskers used
to being both where your body may be but
still with your friends in other places
and time zones you're not texting in
fact I see no little glow of your of
phones that would tell me you were
texting or reading you're paying
attention to social cues to the presence
of others here in the room with you how
they see you too recognizing that you're
now becoming part of something larger
than yourself and that you're now a
berkeley aight a gnome a morsel a
pearson aight a cylinder
or a red lion be in the moment 2015 be
brave allow yourself to fall under the
spell of what you uncover or rediscover
as you come to understand the world in
front of you you will change it and it
will change you thank you